welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 6 chapter
14
the tragedy an episode that spoiler
warning
tragically snatches away from us grogu
and the razor crest but
hey reunites boba fett with his armor
that doesn't really fit him any better
than it did cop bant but you know who it
would fit
grogu he clearly needs it to be honest i
kind of went crazy with this one
i translated the [ __ ] out of boba fett's
chain code and it confirmed some big
stuff about jango fett's history i found
rogue one easter eggs in that prisoner
registry that's
two different alien languages i've
translated for you guys i figured out
stuff about that seeing stone it's runes
even those butterflies there is
a lot let us break it down okay here we
go mando chuckles for the first time
ever i think
playing force catch with grogoo's
favorite toy the spherical knob
originally given to him back in chapter
3 the moment mando really chose to look
after this kid i have speculated the
kid's obsession with it could be
connected with something else spherical
in the star wars universe like
the death star but that scene stone that
he later sits on has a
dome shape that in the closing credits
concept art was originally going to be a
sphere that
jutted up even more from the ground so
maybe those two spheres are connected
some have also speculated that the knob
could be where moff gideon's agent
landed the tracker on the razer crest
there does appear to be a blue part of
the knob that i don't remember seeing
before but considering mando and grogu
had both handled it before the ship was
tracked and they are now i think amanda
would have noticed the weight difference
and we visit tython which looks like
southern california it shows up on
mando's display with the
region listed as core telling us this is
a core
world originally typhon appeared in
legends but has since been made canon in
the dr
aphra novels it is considered one of the
possibilities of the whole origin of the
jedi
alongside other places like achtu and
jedha this seeing stone is located on
the hilltop arranged in a ring with
six boulders propped up with brace
stones now the closing credit concept
art rendered this even more stonehenge
definitely an influence here reflecting
the elemental origins of the jedi that
we saw with the tree in the cave on
achtu this
scene stone might even be linked with
the stone that luke sat atop
in the last jedi kind of opposite ends
of a phone line the scene stone is
marked with these runes
these are written in the language of
erktot aka the old
tongue it is the ancient language of the
sith but it has also been used by both
sides of the force like it showed up in
rebels on the lofall jedi temple but
also the synth temple of malachor
a bunch of other places and animated
series and comics and knights of the old
republic
now unfortunately these runes are just
too worn down and out of focus
to decipher literally letter for letter
but i am
wondering if it could translate to the
jedi code you remember that one there is
no emotion there is peace there is no
ignorance there is knowledge there is no
passion there is serenity there is no
chaos there is harmony there is no death
there is the force
actually the whispers that rey heard
guiding her to that tree
was actually a softly recorded chant of
those words
but uh before i continue i want to thank
bessie shoes for sponsoring this video
bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof they're breathable
so they don't let any liquid in but they
do let the air move
out they also have this antimicrobial
insole
to keep your foot seat smelling good
good like grief karga on a date good
also folks besties shoes are super
stretchy they fit like a sock and they
only weigh 175 grams
it's lighter than some clunky old boots
what are you a storm trooper
they're made with this cool dynamex
material that keeps your feet warm in
cold weather in cool and warm weather
and super easy to clean with just a
splash of water or throw them in the
washing machine
as we head into the snowy and rainy
months it is really great to have
besties for running errands around town
and keeping my feet dry
warm and comfy they really are the
perfect leave by the front door shoes
that you can wear every day
water in my plants water and my plants
wait wait a minute
that's not my plant that's my shoe what
was i
thinking but you know what my shoe may
be soaking wet but my
feet aren't my little piggies are bone
dry in here
thanks to these vessy sneakers
thanks bessie watering my foot water in
my
foot and they have an incredible early
holiday sale
offer right now don't procrastinate and
wait until the last minute to do your
holiday shopping
these are the perfect gift for you and
your loved ones especially for an
upcoming rainy season get them while
they still have sizes and you can thank
me later check them out in the link
below and if you miss a holiday sale
just use my code new rockstars to get 25
off your besties shoes now also visible
on the surface of the stone are these
bluish gray
specks you'll notice they stand out on
mando's visor give you just a little
sign that this is no ordinary boulder
one that is composed of different
sediments with different properties
let's talk about these butterflies these
actually might be connected to the blue
glowy butterflies that darth vader saw
inside his mind as he
meditated in the comic darth vader
number eight it was a super creepy
visual because you see the gnarly way
that vader envisions himself in his
mind's eye but these butterflies
represented the goodness that was still
in him
and that essence might be what swarms
around the stone it is also possible
that these butterflies help activate the
beam
because notice they don't appear to be
visible after it lights up
and i do love how grosgu touches his
fingertips making the classic meditation
gesture
and then after amanda descends the hill
to find boba fett notice how behind him
up by that stone you can see two figures
one presumably the child but who's the
other could this be
a force ghost of master yoda or maybe
luke projecting himself from otch 2 or
maybe it's jean's guy
not clearing the set again your 15
minutes are up now let's talk about
boba fett slave one soars in and lands
it's so freaking exciting to see this
iconic ship after the empire strikes
back and attacking the clones boba fett
carries the rifle and gaby's stick
carried by the tuscan raiders meaning he
probably must have lived among them on
tatooine after he escaped the sarlacc
now i'd explain how
the krait dragon could have dissolved
the sarlacc and that one of those two
beasts stomach acid could have given
boba those scars and discoloration but
hopefully this guy will tell us the
story of how he clawed the hell out of
that thing tamora morrison plays boba
just as he played boba's clone father
jango fett in attack of the clones he
has also since been brought back to
re-record boba fett's audio for the
earlier films i mean folks he really has
been the voice of boba fett so it's
awesome to see him here bubba tells
mando i'm a simple man making his way
through the galaxy
like my father before me it's a direct
callback to
django and attack the clones i'm just a
simple man trying to make my way in the
universe
but i love how this callback adds on
another famous star wars like father
like sun moment
i am a jedi like my father before me
joining boba is sharpshooter bounty
hunter fenik shan confirming boba was
the mystery man who found finnick at the
end of chapter five last season her
gut wound has now been cybernetically
healed with
steam punky abs awesome these two's
partnership reminds me a lot of jango
fett
and zam wessel in attack of the clones
then storm troopers arrive in a drop
ship but not
any dropship this is the transport we
saw the first order use in the force
awakens
and along with that snoke strand cast in
the tub another piece of evidence that
moth gideon's unit might be connected to
the origins of the first order it is
wild to see boba fett take out all these
stormtroopers with the gaffy stick
shattering their armor these sticks have
a club end and a pointed end now the
actor morrison
is part maori his combat style here
evokes the
swinging of a polynesian war club his
expressions are very reminiscent of the
traditional maori warrior face
the stormtroopers drag back out the e
web heavy blaster as we saw in chapter
eight last season originally we saw one
of these set up on hoth and empire
finnick dislodges a boulder and crashes
it with a george lucas raiders of the
lost ark reference
interesting how when mando tries to
remove grogu from the force
beacon it gives and bends a bit before
repelling him
it echoes the way lightsabers are evenly
matched with bescar like these two
forces
aren't magnetic polar opposites that
stiffly and immediately repel each other
but there's some kind of history
a relationship a responsive give and
take between these forces
i also appreciate the audio filter on
mando's voice when we hear it from
inside the field
hey step out of it kid we gotta get out
of here
it's not dubbed in the way that you hear
a voice from underwater when it's coming
from the surface
but it's distorted in this way as if
it's coming through an electronic medium
luke i am your father
now boba fett spots his armor inside the
razor crest and straps himself back
in and notice how he deploys his knee
darts something the visual dictionary
told us he had
but i don't think we've ever seen them
deployed on screen before and then he
uses
rocket to take out both transports so we
don't get too long to celebrate
rip razor crest clearly this season has
been foreshadowing its destruction it's
just been falling in rougher and rougher
shape the blast came from that arkoten's
class light cruiser the same kind of
ship that we've seen in the animated
series
this one is the imperial one commanded
by moff gideon which you saw at the end
of episode four and he deploys
the dark troopers that we saw at the end
of that episode now originally these
were introduced in the dark forces game
these particular ones look like kind of
a cross between the phase two and phase
three dark troopers i love how the
cruiser looms into view from the clouds
and you can first see it in the form of
that shadow on boba's helmet he realizes
that the empire is back this isn't a spy
stream
of course spice the word for drugs in
the star wars universe one of the many
details george lucas lifted from frank
herbert's dune
now the knob and beskar spear are the
only salvageable items from the razor
crest wreckage and then boba confirms
his backstory my chain code has been
encoded in the sama for 25 years
see this is me what about that
this is my father jango fett their
father was a foundling
yes even fought in the mandalorian
civil wars okay lots to unpack here this
language is
mandoa it is the written form of the
mandalorian language it actually first
appeared on slave one in attack of the
clones and i
have taken the time to translate it for
you now on the far right is boba
and that his name added on to the end of
this but if you go over to the far
left it reads foundling took into
the year the concord dawn
mentor jaster father phet
now the h's do look more like english
lowercase h's than they do the mandoa
ages
but everything else lines up i'm pretty
sure this is what it says and i love it
this
is how mando can confirm boba's lineage
and django's confirmed mandalorian
foundling past
this all comes from a jango fett origin
comic which
wasn't until now considered to be canon
because clone wars season 2
cast django's origin in doubt with the
line from olmec jungle fett was a common
bounty hunter
how he acquired that armor is beyond me
and at the time george lucas and even
dave filoni seemed pretty clear their
intent was that jango fett would not be
a true mandalorian so the idea that
jango
fett is not a mandalorian that's
something that comes directly from
george but now it looks like bologna is
apparently bat-battling a bit either way
we can definitely interpret almex line
as a snob a prime planet mandalorian
thumbing his nose at
mandalorians from other planets and
moons in the system because concord
dawn was django's home world it's also
in the mandalore system
jaster refers to jasper muriel another
mandalorian who was
on the run exiled from concord dawn
actually was pursued by members of the
death watch who ended up
killing django's parents for sheltering
jaster
jaster ended up taking jango under his
wing training him
in a separate rival mandalorian clan to
the watch a group calling themselves the
true mandalorians meanwhile the watch
was the group that eventually found
denjarin and took him in as a foundling
so boba fett and denjarin
end up hailing from rival mandalorian
clans but as mando learned from poketan
earlier this season
the old divisions within mandalorians
don't really matter after the purge
there really aren't enough mandalorians
left for them to turn against each other
meanwhile the mandalorian civil war that
boba referred to took place
prior to the phantom menace the
mandalorians at the time were divided
over whether to be pacifists or
militaristic like their ancestors house
wiesla led the whole warrior side to
that debate they ended up losing the
civil war they were banished to the moon
of concordia
where the death watch was founded and by
the way during this time obi-wan kenobi
and qui-gon jinn were stationed on
mandalore to protect the true
mandalorian air duchess sateen which is
when that younger obi-wan did fall in
love with her so they end up taking
slave one back to navarro where mando
learns cara dunes badge from that x-wing
captain makes her an
official marshal of the new republic her
prisoner registry is filled with orbesh
rap
sheets and uh you know i have you
covered let's break them down
first we got vorg awesome and then
skirto
tobbs then torbill danzen i'm not sure
yet
but i would not be surprised if a lot of
these guys are just crew and or friends
of the series then
nylocks cabin roves then pretze rolotto
who i might be crazy to me this guy
looks a lot like andrew ray from binging
with babbage who
just did an episode with john favreau to
make those blue cookies
i love his channel i want to meet to him
that sounded gross anyway gaprin
dosito is up next this same droid race
was the bandit from chapter 9
and the dude who yelled at rey in the
force awakens and he does have a gap
grin
then we got biran redbin he tried to
snatch grogu on tatooine then
abrac kefunni then a nicto named
em dwello d he might be the necto on
tatooine or maybe one of the niktos who
is guarding him on arvala seven in
chapter one
next there is a mon calamari named a
host la fular
then a zabrak named thien cross then a
coroner named yath
indeedy this little nightmare is named
sart
julos then an aqualish the same race as
panda baba
and the others cara dune just took out
named unga toba and then cheekbones here
is named sethro
daggery and then bourbon todds now the
last bunch are shown much closer so you
can see their crimes and locations
there's
torbil danzen that's a tuscan raider who
is held
at sunspot prison for attempted
kidnapping of a senator
interesting then cardo dives is in
wobani penitentiary
you should recognize that that's the
prison jyn erso started in in rogue one
volvani an anagram for obi-wan that by
the way was an imperial prison so i
guess now it's a new republic
operation cardo is being held for
assault of a new republic officer next
there's a gemorian
named target low held on garen 4
for aggravated assault and then lastly
the return of bill burr
as migs may build from chapter 6 last
season imprisoned on the carthon
chop fields probably where we are headed
next episode as meadow busts him free
he needs him to track down moff gideon
probably because mayfeld used to be an
imperial and the next screen shows that
migs is charged with facilitating the
escape of a prisoner
and accessory to the death of a new
republic officer we saw
all of that go down in chapter six last
season and it came back up with those
new republic pilots in chapter nine mob
gideon leaves the bridge of his cruiser
as it blasts through hyperspace to the
brig where grogu is kept he thrashes
around those stormtroopers and
force chokes one another example of a
force choke it's more commonly a dark
side use of the force though remember
luke did force choke those gomorian
guards at java's palace mothgation is
thrilled
to see this proof that grogu is very
force sensitive
because it is a confirmation that he is
a viable donor for dr pershing and all
their strand cast genetic experiments
and then he shows off the dark saber
what a dick since grogu was trained in
the jedi temple he wouldn't use
training sabers but the crystals
powering those are much weaker the
blades don't really cut through anything
and then poor grogu gets stunned that
same blue polygon visual that was used
to stun leia in the first film and his
adorable little cuffs emit this blue
glow which might be connected to the
ray shield that inhibited obi wan's use
of the force when dooku captured him and
the last detail i will leave you with
is that little moment when the dark
saber retracts such things
lively put an eye out one of these i
notice how the dark saber doesn't give
off quite the same
hum and zip that other sabers do its
retraction is less of a z
then uh it's like the saber is alive
which is ironic because it is
ancient it might be the oldest
lightsaber in existence
and maybe it's just that it is now the
holiday season but it is not a good idea
for gideon to say you'll put an eye out
with this thing one of john fabro's best
friends is
peter billingsley aka box of scraps
william guinta riva in the mcu
because favreau let him cameo in iron
man this guy is grown up ralphie from a
christmas story folks the kid who
famously was warned you'll shoot your
eye
out with his favorite toy weapon that
faithfully does just that and the way
life gideon now
toys with this thing like a freaking red
rider air rifle
i'm calling it now he is gonna poke his
eye out with that dark saber or grogu
will do it for him we do know that
giancarlo esposito loves his freaky
violent ends
by the way we still have tons of great
mandalorian apparel options available
for purchase at our merch store
newaxersmerch.com
i think we got a few this is the way red
or white options left but we also have
this awesome grogu mugshot shirt a ton
of other lovely designs
they're all great holiday gift options
folks but we have learned that the
various shipping services cannot
guarantee a christmas delivery this year
for you know obvious reasons so you
really gotta jump on this now
before monday the 7th at the latest so
hopefully everything can get to you and
your loved ones in time
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification button follow me on
instagram
ea boss follow me rockstars thank you
for watching i have spoken
[Music]
you